[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo aurait on parle cette
semaine des 30 ans du programme erasmus
un succès à contester a lancé en 1987 il
a permis à plus de 5 millions de jeunes
à de partir à l'étranger soit 270 mille
par an parmi cette génération erasmus
beaucoup on en retirait une conscience
plus forte un d'être européen
aujourd'hui le programme s'ouvre à de
nouveaux profils avec erasmus plus
et puis l'europe veut rendre le
programme erasmus plus accessible à le
montant des bourses et les opportunités
de stages à l'étranger vont augmenter
dès la rentrée 2010 8 on en débat avec
nos invités jean arthuis bonjour vous
êtes député européen français de
l'alliance des démocrates et libéraux
pour l'europe à centriste vous suivez de
près ce programme erasmus plus à vous
allez nous en parler karima delli
bonjour d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes député européenne française du
groupe des verts mais avant de parler
d'erasmus à d'une des trente ans
d'erasmus l'actualité de cette semaine
c'est le glyphosate à cet herbicide
controversé l'europe a réautorisé le
clivot ata pour cinq ans à 18 pays ont
voté pour pour la commission a ainsi
obtenu la majorité qualifiée requise
lâché par l'allemagne la france assure
qu'elle interdira l'herbicide au plus
tard dans trois ans françois goulard
c'est un coup dur pour la france
l'italie et les sept autres pays
européens opposés à la prolongation de
glyphosate la proposition de la
commission européenne de reconduire
l'autorisation de l'herbicide pour cinq
ans a été finalement retenue une
décision que regrette le ministre de la
transition écologique faut voir d'où on
vient
si on n'était pas intervenus je pense
que honoraires voter une autorisation
pour dix ans
cinq ans c'est trop long et les mesures
d'accompagnement me semble-t-il pour
l'instant sont insuffisantes mais bon
c'est le jeu des institutions
européennes il faut le respecter
maintenant on va regarder ce que la
france peut faire de son côté emmanuel
macron a tout de suite annoncé une date
butoir pour le glyphosate en france j'ai
demandé au gouvernement de prendre les
dispositions nécessaires pour que
l'utilisation du glyphosate soit
interdite en france
dès que des alternatives auront été
trouvés et au plus tard dans trois ans
les associations de défense de
l'environnement prennent le président au
mot donc il s'engage du langage du
gouvernement français on sera vigilant à
ce que cette promesse soit respecté et
on contribuera avec d'autres a aidé à ce
qu'elle le soin à bruxelles
c'est l'allemagne qui a fait pencher la
balance jusque l'abstentionniste berlin
a finalement voté pour
créant une division au sein même du
gouvernement
dans le camp de la france l'italie et
l'autriche était également inquiet des
conséquences du glyphosate classées
cancérigènes probables par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
[Musique]
karima delli c'est un revers pour la
france c'est un coup dur c'est un coup
dur mais en même temps la france a
toujours dit qu'elle était pour
justement une interdiction
et comme le dit nicolas hulot les
premières négociations s'étaient
renouvellement après dix ans aujourd'hui
on est sur cinq ans et le gouvernement
français s'engage pour trois ans
maintenant il faut mettre en oeuvre
toutes les alternatives et faire en
sorte d'accompagner aussi nos
agriculteurs parce que c'est eux aussi
qui aujourd'hui utilisent grandement le
glyphosate est de montrer que oui
baho chimiques ya du mécanique et docks
et des alternatives mais faut y aller de
manière rapide efficace
qu'est ce que ça signifie pour les
agriculteurs français
la france elle elle veut arrêter
l'utilisation du glyphosate d'ici trois
ans est-ce qu'on peut interdire des
produits autorisés par l'europe à
empêcher nos agriculteurs français
d'aller s'approvisionner en allemagne
pas seulement les agriculteurs mais les
consommateurs
j'avoue ma perplexité parce que le
marché il est européen et s'imposer des
contraintes sans doute coûteuse au nom
de la santé publique ces vertus
incontestablement mais dans un marché
qui est européen c'est prendre le risque
d'être marginalisé sur ce marché
donc ce que je souhaite c'est que tous
les efforts soient accomplis dans le
domaine de la recherche pour mettre au
point des produits de substitution et
puis enfin je voudrais dire que ceux des
agriculteurs qui entendent produire sans
avoir recours au glyphosate
c'est leur responsabilité et peut-être
peuvent-ils tenir un discours en
direction des consommateurs leurs
produits seront sans doute plus cher que
les produits de la concurrence
mais si les consommateurs sont désireux
de se mettre à l'abri des conséquences
d'éventuelles préjudiciable du
glyphosate
il pourrait à ce moment là faire ce
choix donc responsabilité des
agriculteurs
on a interrogé les français sur les
faisait huit français sur dix sont
contre le mifo that parce qu'ils ont
conscience que les conséquences vont
être dramatiques sur leur santé
mais aussi sur leur environnement le
glyphosate chaath a le sentiment qu'on
sourit je sais tu vois la double nous on
il faut se dire on met en place
oui le principe de précaution maintenant
il faut c'est une révolution parce qu'on
a ça fait 30 ans qu'on est dans un
modèle agricole qui et productiviste est
donc aujourd'hui c'est tout là une
nouvelle réorientation de notre
agriculture qui va falloir faire c'est
pour ça qu'il faut accompagner les
agriculteurs montrer qu'il ya d'autres
alternatives parce que sur nos
territoires on a des belles pratiques et
faire en sorte que demain bas nos
consommateurs mangent mieux avec des
produits de qualité et surtout faire
attention à leur santé
en attendant le pivot atterri autorisé
en europe pour cinq ans c'est quoi c'est
la victoire des lobbys de l'industrie
agrochimique comment il ya débat il ya
une forte suspicion
ce revirement de l'allemagne de conflit
d'intérêt entre les chercheurs
j'avoue que je n'arrive pas à me faire
une opinion
on a des rapports très contradictoires
dans leurs conclusions
je reconnais que le principe de
précaution dans le cas particulier
pourrait trouver à s'appliquer
mais encore une fois nous avons être
très très vigilant parce que on va
s'imposer des contraintes particulières
en europe et au même moment l'europe
négocié avec le monde entier avec le
mercosur avec l'australie avec que la
nouvelle zélande et donc créer des
contraintes que devront assumer nos
agriculteurs alors même qu'on ouvre le
marché très largement attention et le
maquereau on parle fréquemment d'une
europe qui doit nous protéger je
souhaite pour ma part que l'on met en
cohérence les dispositions qui sont
prises au plan sanitaire plan de la
santé publique et le commerce extérieur
mai mais on peut dire quand même que
c'est la victoire des lobbys pourquoi
parce que on s'appuie sur des études
sauf que ces études et ça a été prouvé
que des chercheurs ont été financés par
monsanto et ont montré que nous ne vous
inquiétez pas circulez ya rien à voir
puisque le bifff êtes né se disant pas
cancérigène
l'om est ce le dis aujourd'hui on
des chiffres ne prenons pas les citoyens
et les consommateurs en cobayes on ne
peut pas jouer avec la santé publique et
donc ce qui est grave dans cette
histoire c'est que dans cinq ans on va
jouer le même essayer de garder le
travail des lobbys aurait des
conséquences sur le choix des états on
se sait qu ils ont des regards ils sont
pas ici au parlement européen regardez
l'allemagne je veux dire on sait que la
fusion bayard moss entonné un n'est pas
sans conséquences derrière on sait très
bien que plus allemande qui a racheté
mons on va l'annoncer on sait qu'ici le
poids des lobbys est très très fort
maintenant la question est de savoir si
les nous la france
oui j'ai moi je fais confiance notamment
au gouvernement qui s'engage sur une
interdiction après trois ans donc on a
trois ans pour réunir les acteurs
accompagner nos agriculteurs et faire en
sorte que nous soyons les leaders des
produits de qualité c'est ça qu'on
attend aussi de la france on le souhaite
que la france puisse convaincre ses
partenaires dans les trois ans qui
viennent pour que tous les pays
européens appliquent le même dispositif
la même prohibition du glyphosate et que
l'europe se donne les moyens de revoir
les traités de libre échange qui laisse
venir sur le marché des produits qui
sans doute ont pas respecté les normes
que nous nous imposons et que nous
imposons à nos propres producteurs et
agriculteurs
donc oui à la souveraineté alimentaire
oui à la sécurité alimentaire mais
tirons-en les conséquences en termes de
libre échange ale on passe maintenant
notre partie magazine les 30 ans du
programme erasmus est ce reportage en
espagne un heureux comme erasmus à
grenade
avec près de 2300 étudiants erasmus
chaque année la ville espagnole a vu son
université bondir dans le classement de
shanghai et la vieille cité andalouse
s'est mué on a lieu dynamique ouvert sur
le monde le reportage à grenade de rym
ben ameur
à la hausse il est 19 heures c'est
l'heure de l'apéritif dans cette
colocation d'étudiants erasmus de
grenade
l'occasion de se raconter leur journée à
la fac comme ça deux italiennes
une mexicaine et un français partagent
cet appartement
le français cet homme il est arrivé à
grenade il ya trois semaines
à 19 ans c'est son premier saut dans
l'inconnu pour moi c'est l'émancipation
ray complète indépendance de ma famille
de mes parents c'est la vie tout seul
comme pouvoir me débrouiller seuls pour
nous prouver même que le public tout
seul loin de mon pays loin de ma famille
et après un produit culturel c'est
surtout aussi way m'ouvrir sur le monde
entier quoi ne plus rester uniquement
son cadre français avec ma culture ma
langue mais aussi apprendre de nouvelles
choses tous les jours sur des pays qui
peut être super loin tant que avec ses
colocataires
ils sortent plusieurs fois par semaine
et compte bien profiter de cette année
de fête mais l'erasmus c'est surtout une
année pour se former
tom est étudiant en droit il est passé
des amphis d'orléans à ceux de la
faculté de sang de pablo
tous les cours sont en espagnol et il
faut tenir le rythme au début on a du
mal à parler avec tout le monde parce
que on a un peu limité en terme de
langage
après niveau scolaire c'est vrai que les
premiers cours en espagnol on sort du
court avec une barre une barre juste ici
parce que la prof à des beats dont cd
démo technique on connaît pas forcément
et ils ont dit en axant un peu
particulier ici donc ça que
l'intégration au niveau de la ville a
été très rapide et c'est réussi et
intégration scolaire elle demande plus
de temps quand même parce que il faut
s'habituer au rythme où des profs est un
système qui est différent de la france
justement
[Musique]
comme top plus de 2300 étudiants
étrangers viennent this chaque année
pour leurs échanges universitaires entre
de croquer d'un côté la ville est très
attractive
d'un autre côté grenade est une faculté
qui comptent qui a un certain prestige
et qui est reconnu pour sa qualité
d'accueil donc d'une année sur l'autre
les gens se passent le mot et c'est ce
qui fait que grenade et la première
faculté pour l'accueil des étudiants
étrangers viennent par morgan parra
l'autre argument de la ville andalouse
c'est le coût de la vie peu élevés avec
des colocations à 300 euros en moyenne
les étudiants erasmus ont une bourse de
1500 euros par an la faculté elle ne
reçoit pas de subventions de l'union
européenne mais elle gagne beaucoup
comme la ville de grenade militaire
portant à la fois en trente ans quarante
mille étudiants apporté à la ville une
richesse multiculturelle
ces jeunes apportent avec eux leur mode
de vie leur manière de penser
c'est aussi une importante richesse
économique
chaque année ces étudiants rapporte 15 à
20 millions d'euros à la ville
en trente ans près de cinq millions de
personnes ont pu faire l'expérience
erasmus à travers toute l'europe depuis
2014 le programme des changes s'est
transformé en erasmus plus soit des
partenariats avec plus de 169 pays du
monde entier
il s'est aussi ouvert aux apprentis et
aux chômeurs d'ici à 2020 2 millions
d'européens supplémentaire pourrait
profiter de cette expérience
internationale
[Musique]
voilà pour ce très beau reportage à
grenade de rim benameur genre depuis
trente ans après un quel bilan vous
faites du programme erasmus belle idée
qui a bien marché très positif lorsqu'on
interroge des européens et qu'on leur
demande quels sont à leurs yeux les
symboles de l'europe c'est la monnaie
l'euro et ses erasmus et on a fêté le
trentième anniversaire avec ses
manifestations erasmus gelais dans toute
l'europe
je crois que c'est un dé à des grands et
beaux programmes parce que c'est une
façon aussi pour les jeunes d'aller à la
rencontre d'autres pratiques
d'enseignement
d'autres n'ont pas de culture parce que
les européens ont les mêmes valeurs mais
c'est une façon de sortir de sa zone de
confort
et puis c'est dans ces conditions que la
citoyenneté européenne se renforce et
que l'on jette là les fondations les
plus sûres pour la construction
européenne
karima delli ya quand même des critiques
à ses étudiants erasmus qui restent
entre eux qui n'est pas la leur qu'ils
parlent pas la langue du pays de la
population qui se mélange pas avec la
population est ce qu'on peut pas faire
mieux et casser cette image de
l'espagnol ya eu plusieurs images deyres
musique d'abord ça a été dit comme un
programme élitiste c'est à dire c'est ça
qu'est ce ça favoriser une certaine
population de jeunes aujourd'hui
erasmus plus ça concerne tout le monde
et même les jeunes les plus défavorisés
donc ça c'est un plus la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il était au départ juste pour
des étudiants aujourd'hui on voir le
panel est agrandi on aura les apprentis
ça c'est très important on a aussi des
chômeurs et j'entendais monsieur
moscovici qui va même pousser pour dire
et c'est bien aidé il faudra même
l'ouvrir notamment aux migrants donc
tout ça ça va dans le bon sens mais le
résultat il est certes satisfaisant
parce qu on a l'image renforcement de la
citoyenneté
et puis sur sur le cv c'est un plus pour
les jeunes
ceux qui ont une expérience à l'étranger
dans leur cv c'est considéré par les
employeurs comme un avantage
considérable maintenant au bout de 30
ans on regarde c'est 9 millions de
personnes 9 millions de personnes c'est
pas beaucoup
et donc là il va falloir se donner des
objectifs et moi je crois que notre
objectif c'est un de sauver le budget
notamment d'erasmus dans la période qui
va arriver mais aussi permettre aux
jeunes anglais parce qu'avec le break si
on se pose la question de que vont
devenir ces jeunes anglais est ce qu'ils
vont pouvoir encore avoir recours à ce
programme erasmus
et la deuxième chose c'est pousser sur
des nouveaux programmes et là je suis
d'accord avec le avec mon collègue est
aujourd'hui qui montre à quel point
oui la place des apprentis elle est
également sur cette erasmus et on va
voir comment vous allez gérer la
question notamment des contrats de
travail qui est gestion importants
d'inclure les apprentis dans le
programme erasmus a dit pourquoi les
exclure pourquoi les exclure notre
ambition n'est ce que les apprentis et
les mêmes droits d'accès rh luche que
les étudiants voient bien qu'il ya des
apprentis qui partent en mobilité by
partent en moyenne deux semaines
ce qui n'est pas satisfaisant donc nous
allons déposer un projet pilote pour
l'expérimentation et karima delli avait
été signataire projet pilote pour
expérimenter pour essayer de comprendre
pourquoi ça marchait pas pour les
apprentis et ça marche pas contrairement
aux étudiants un étudiant à l'université
ils ont passé des accords à bologne bon
on reconnaît mutuellement les acquis de
cette mobilité lorsqu'on va une année à
grenade ou dans d'autres pays de l'union
européenne mais pour les apprentis 28
pays ça veut dire pratiquement 28 statut
différent de l'apprentissage
l'apprentissage c'est à la fois à
contrat de travail et c'est un contrat
de formation professionnelle et ce que
nous voulons c'est permettre aux
apprentis de partir mais pas seulement
quinze jours c'est très bien qu'un jour
parce que ça leur donne envie de partir
mais ce que nous voulons c'est qu'il
puisse y avoir une véritable immersion
sion dans le pays c'est dans ces
conditions qu'on parle une autre langue
que la langue du pays d'origine et c'est
une façon de démocratiser erasmus que de
l'ouvrir aux apprentis c'est aussi un
moyen de lutter contre le chômage c'est
un instrument extraordinaire parce que
si nous avons lancé ce projet pilote
c'est parce que nous avons un vrai
scandale en europe le chômage du jeune
un jeune sur quatre est au chômage et
dans certains pays c'est un jeune sur
deux sauf dans les quelques pays
l'allemagne les pays bas l'autriche le
danemark qui ont une tradition
d'apprentissage enraciné dans la culture
économique sociale éducative
donc nous avons tout à gagner en allant
à la rencontre des autres pour appliquer
les bonnes pratiques
c'est notre détermination et j'ai bon
espoir qu'on y arrive parce que la
commission vient de reprendre à son
compte d'autres projets pilotes et pour
la période 2018 2019 et 2020 et la
fléche et 400 millions pour la mobilité
longue de cinquante mille apprentis
c'est un premier pas maintenant pour que
ça fonctionne il faut qu'on commence à
lever les obstacles par exemple en
france
le contrat d'apprentissage ne peut pas
être suspendu ça veut dire que si un
jeune parent pendant une année
il est toujours sous la responsabilité
juridique de son maître d'apprentissage
français s'ils un accident c'est le
maître d'apprentissage français qui sera
tenu pour responsable et c'est le maître
d'apprentissage français qui doit le
rémunérer voilà pourquoi ça ne
fonctionne pas donc gouvernement va
confier une mission pour faire des
propositions dans le cadre un projet de
loi qui va venir au printemps devant le
parlement français pour précisément
réforme et l'apprentissage mais aussi
lever les freins à la mobilité pour les
apprentis karima delli les jeunes
erasmus sont souvent issus des milieux
favorisés c'est ce que disent les
enquêtes comment fait pour démocratiser
un peu un peu plus tout cela mais bon il
faut en parler il faut que la formation
erasmus soit partout le problème c'est
que souvent ce soit c'est dans les
sciences po ça c'est dans les grandes
facs etc
il faut que ce soit partout notamment
dans les lycées professionnels ça moi
j'insiste sur ça parce que justement ils
ont accès
et ils ont droit à ces races médoc il
faut y aller il faut faire des vraies
campagnes nationales sur erasmus
aujourd'hui on voit bien que erasmus
c'est ça a été souvent au début du
bouche à oreille tout le monde connaît
ce soit un problème d'information selon
wenn man à scania ça et ensuite il ya
aussi cette barrière de la langue
souvent beaucoup de personnes et de
jeunes ont peur de faire erasmus parce
qu'ils se disent on va pas y arriver
parce que je ne connais pas bien la
langue du pays est bien là il faut les
encourager à dire justement le but c'est
un de permettre de découvrir une autre
langue mais surtout erasmus et on le dit
pas assez c'est que ça permet aux jeunes
de se découvrir soi-même et je pense que
ça en termes de capacités
intellectuelles et de capacité de
projets etc
c'est véritablement un avantage
considérable qu'on l'a dit le montant
des bourses à et les opportunités de
stages à l'étranger vont augmenter dès
la rentrée 2010 8 dit pierre moscovici
mais en même temps le succès 1 du
programme dépasse actuellement les
capacités budgétaires prévues en 2017
s'il avait fallu accepter toutes les
demandes en france à 49 millions d'euros
supplémentaires auraient été nécessaires
ya un risque que les financements ne
soit pas à la hauteur des ambitions il
faut de nouveaux contributeurs au
programme c'est le premier à quitter
votre lions européenne on a des
programmes qui fonctionnent bien
je pense à un programme de recherche
qu'on appelle horizon 20 20 c'est
l'avenir de l'europe
on écarte 89% des projets éligibles
parce que on a annoncé un dispositif
n'en a pas les crédits correspondants
erasmus c'est pareil c'est une machine à
faire de la frustration puisque
pratiquement on écarte la moitié des
demeurés
le budget global pour erasmus sur la
période 2014 2020 c'est un peu plus de
14 milliards
mais ça suffit pas et donc il va falloir
que nos chefs d'état et de gouvernement
qui ont eu des propos lyrique à
l'occasion de la célébration du 30e
anniversaire met les actes à la hauteur
des paroles ce sera le mot de la fin en
tout cas merci à vous deux de nous avoir
parlé de ce programme erasmus à qui fête
ses 30 ans avait parlé du futur aussi
on passe à notre rubrique de fact
checking cette commission a soumis au
conseil et au parlement plus de
propositions en matière de fiscalité que
n'importe quel autre commission
antérieur c'est jean claude juncker a le
patron de la commission qu'il le dit
vrai faux c'est checkpoint préparé par
thomas mignon les propositions
législatives de la commission européenne
dans le domaine de la fiscalité le
président jean claude juncker s'est
félicité de son bilan lors d'un passage
en belgique cette commission dit il a
soumis au conseil et au parlement plus
de propositions en la matière que
n'importe quel autre commission
antérieur combien la commission une
guerre at-elle soumis deux propositions
toutes matières confondues l'actuelle
commission européenne a fait 949
proposition au parlement et au conseil
européen depuis son entrée en fonction
en novembre 2014 mais retireront tout ce
qui se rapporte à la migration la santé
la mobilité ou encore l'environnement
pour ne finalement gardé que la
fiscalité au sens le plus large
nous obtenons 93 proposition législative
alors est ce mieux que tout autre
commission et bien si l'on remonte dans
le temps jusqu'à la première équipe de
commissaires présidé par walter
hallstein on voit que la fiscalité
n'avait pas le même poids ou la même
importance
il faut attendre les équipes de jacques
delors pour voir un sursaut des
propositions fiscales
mais c'est à la commission de romano
prodi que l'on doit le plus important
nombre avec pas moins de 159 texte
proposé soit bien mieux que l'actuelle
commission
alors pourquoi jean claude juncker se
permet-il cette affirmation est bien
difficile à dire car pour l'instant sur
le seul critère de quantité il n'y a
qu'en réduisant le champ aux textes liés
à l'évasion et l'optimisation fiscale
que l'on parvient à peine à faire
remonter sa commission sur le podium
là l'équipe juncker a fait 18
propositions qui la place juste derrière
son prédécesseur josé manuel barosso
l'avantagent revient uniquement à une
guerre d'un point de vue proportionnelle
ramené au nombre de propositions par 100
jours de mandat cela fait une
proposition réguler 6 et là c'est un
fait
personne n'a encore fait mieux dans
l'histoire de la commission barroso
deuxième est à un texte véhicules 16 sur
l'évasion par 100 jours de présidence
reste qu'en termes absolu dire que
l'équipe juncker a soumis le plus de
propositions législatives sur la
fiscalité alors thomann mignon nous a
rejoints c'est vous le grand ordonnateur
de cette rubrique de fact checking c'est
reparti pour une nouvelle saison
mais oui une nouvelle saison de
checkpoint donc notre séquence de fact
checking c'est-à-dire de vérification
par les faits et comme l'année dernière
bien les personnalités publiques n'ont
qu'à bien se tenir
qu'ils soient députés nationaux
européens qu'ils soient ministres chefs
d'état ou même commissaire européen
voire même président de la commission
comme on vient de le voir nous passerons
leurs déclarations à l'épreuve de notre
thermomètre de la vérité pour voir si
leurs déclarations sont plutôt dans le
show dans le froid de la véracité des
faits avec une nouveauté vous êtes vous
êtes vous n'êtes pas tout seul à
regarder à toute une expérience voilà
cette année toute une équipe de la rtb
se mobilisera pour et se relaiera pour
vous proposer chaque semaine une
séquence de fact checking donc check
polt et bien merci thomas a checkpoint
n'dri très apprécié ici à europe hebdo
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi restez avec nous
assure les chaînes parlementaires et la
rtbf bail
[Musique]